where does this all lead as the can of
worms has been opened as pandora's box
is opening as democrats and media are
starting to talk about the fact that joe
biden is not well that the country is in
bad shape all of those things it's
starting to pilfer out mainstream can't
hold it much longer even don lemon over
on cnn he's starting to get it by god
he's getting it i can't believe it does
the president have the stamina
physically and mentally do you think to
continue on even after 2024.
you're asking me this question oh my
gosh he's the president of the united
states you know he i can't even keep up
with it we just got back from new mexico
we just got back from california uh that
is
i
i
that is not a question that we should be
even asking just look at the work that
he does and look what he's how he's
delivering uh for the american public
look that what that that that article
that we're talking about is hearsay it's
salacious that's not what we care about
we care about how we going to deliver
for the american people how are we going
to make their lives better that's what
the president talks about that is his
focus
and that's where we're going to continue
uh to focus on grandpa's okay grandpa's
okay sure he pooped in his pants he
doesn't know where he is but don't ask
us any questions about that he's okay
he's okay well that response got her
into a lot of trouble because people
watched that response
which was obviously just sort of punting
it in the way she laughed it off and
it's like she knows everyone knows
that's what we all must do we must stop
participating in the lie we all know
something's wrong with joe biden it is
what it is i don't take any great joy in
that right he's the pilot of the plane
the united states is the plane i wish
the pilot was competent he ain't
but her muddled answer got her into even
more trouble so she put out this tweet
to be clear which is what they always
say to be clear as the president has
said repeatedly he plans to run in 2024.
so okay that's more pr nonsense it's
just more lying he is not running in
2024 as a matter of fact uh if you're in
the mainstream media and you watch the
reuben report by you know hosted by dave
rubin uh what i might recommend you do
is every time a well-known democrat is
out there let's say a hillary clinton or
a barack obama they should only be asked
one thing
will you support joe biden in 2024 and
let's see how honest they are because
they all know he ain't gonna run and
they know that they won't be supporting
him a because he's not gonna run but
they wouldn't support him anyway because
this whole thing is a complete
farce
but the other interesting piece of that
is if you flash back to the video that i
showed you a few minutes ago when peter
ducey asked her about joe biden running
she was said oh i'm not allowed to say
anything like that uh then of course she
puts out a tweet saying just that so
there's some inconsistency there too
okay so be it uh let's go back to don
lamont who i don't know what's going on
with don maybe maybe what do you think
happened maybe he had some mushroom
supplements or something something's
going on but don at least had a moment
or two of not being horrifically awful
economists do cite the war in ukraine
and supply chain issues we did have that
before the war supply chain issues they
also say that last year's stimulus
package which you mentioned contributed
to inflation korean does the biden
administration bear some responsibility
for this so first of all um
the american rescue plan met the moment
and it has put us in a place where we
can actually uh uh put us in a place
where the american people feel can can
actually we can take on inflation what i
mean by that is we see we've seen growth
right with a as i mentioned more than
eight million jobs and now we're
transitioning into a steady a stable
growth the president actually wrote an
op-ed to discuss that himself talk lay
out his plan on how we're going to bring
down inflation and so that's really
important in order uh to take this on we
got to have some be in a good historic
economic place which is where we are
right now all right lemon look man
when you get one right i'll credit you
so good for you yes the right question
again she keeps saying the complete
reverse of the truth the american rescue
plan is it's something like you know
it's nothing she just says nothing but
it's sort of like oh this thing put us
in a place to kind of know what we're
doing so maybe we're going to get better
and things will be okay and i hope so
no the american rescue plan is what
added to the deficit it is what added to
inflation it was printing more money
that we don't have that has caused this
very problem but these people are all so
deep
they are so deep in the lies that they
don't know how to get out of it
you